bongi romandie digamos steve jobs hoax
sobre as dificuldades em aprender línguas
importância de tomar solenidade sim se
foi gusta de sos romeo notícias vídeos por
favor escreve se você clicar em quem embora
para notificações e ou para qualquer pessoa que faça uma sóbria
obter lodo no idioma e em inglês
vídeo de notícias maiori at demis em idioma
Inglês e foi importante pong jesús
vídeos e nenhuma liga para aprender
pouco para a frase blasi é melhor uma maneira de
leva as camadas de mojito Shkoder inglês
e estarei lá para melhorar mini rea
true mini é um português mas eu me importo
ossos problema um problema e nota e
muito tempo porque então eu sou
Aprendendo
uma língua perdida em árabe não
terminou o tempo parecia levar um
gíria do tabuleiro de xadrez eu vou deixar claro
melhorar e experimentar o ambiente do problema que
é como se com a língua espanhola ed
para edifícios me cria um ambiente ou
criar neurônios psonis cass
não precisa mano para fa llarme ior e um
português
você pode influenciá-lo pela linguagem
espanhol, mas ofereci isso conectado e
espanhol
me ajuda muito pois é coesis
desde a o vocabulário e mais o menos o
mismo e al dos ddos ​​idiotas e resumindo é
até mesmo situações de ipsos para
example pt no brasil que leva um
seu primeiro era uma língua estrangeira e única
maneira de melhorar e passar o tempo
o tempo discutir o mito de lehár é
Eu quase comando que vídeos de produções
quem manteve que eu não canalizo eni glass o
silverstein estudando outros idiomas che
lese importani importação sos importação
o famoso s1000 não os fará suar
cadeira se for chamado de extensão do navegador que
facilita a importação
alguma contagem de conteúdo
netflix youtube youtube e contra paras
em suma, é necessário um conteúdo de conteúdo
para est dar
desde tomar ciência na língua
não se torcedor e na sala de aula eu não sirvo não sirvo e
parece que é um sistema de conexões neuronais
cas que cria mestres um sentido picasso
legais
estes são meses difíceis de fises nous nous
faire bros em campo para interpretar
ex estrangeiro picasso e você gás maicon multa
estímulo muito estímulo semana trans
experiência com outro idioma
através da leitura lendo ea
discutir moscas para confienza que um
sério tente me levar mas de acordo com según
então condicione o exemplo prodi bend acres
pegar milho facilmente porque um
criar-me vou observar milho flexi real
de pol e zanus já observaram myzone
menos treinado e informado para
otimizar o otimismo para a operação
uma língua materna ou se tiver uma
inglês português que se juntou ao
momento e sorriso fase difícil de entrar
um além do idioma é um pouco um pouco lá
situação em que eu me atraso
internet mas resumindo e não negou 20
línguas eto'o quem observa quem sabe é um pouco
milho preto prata que uma pessoa que
Eu vou fazer um idioma agora no prédio
alguns tris cérebro se formam depois dele
Espanhol entra
é uma correção para o kansas como nimer
que é ou que rieti de poder expressar
armin mais naturalmente com seu próprio salto
e milho natural e em milho português o
tempo de myism ou feto que conectou e
espanhol
me ajuda muito porque vocabulário e
espanhol 90 por cento o mismo que em
Português é um ism mi smart isa a
contextos e com poços porque quem sabe talvez
inglês português e inglês borboleta a
pressione uma língua estrangeira que vai para
pegue
o nome estava criando palcos principais
interessados ​​últimos mentos fine scholes
que desce de como e espanhol para guiá-lo é
um obstáculo, porém, meu tempo me ajuda e
voz você está interessado e você estava
expõe adquirir conteúdo buscar
músicas interessantes e livros de audiolivros
filmes netflix e youtube interesse e
cosas que corresponde à experiência
iaastd ganancioso por ser gay
é bem vezes que criou
não é em si mesmo para Kriens ser capaz de ter sucesso
rápido o suficiente para fazê-lo, mas é conhecido
ou vocabulário em suv em solene guà
eram um vocabulário e sua posição
idioma a língua materna que os acres lidam
notas eu entro com interesse susy com seu
experiência como um vocabulário e em solene
ai de um português são 20 gensse
que seca e vai me puxando diz
as horas para se juntar ao adulto em inglês sim
pode continuar a camada scutari
interessado em plein inconveniente inglês
tudo depende da sala de aula não
escola não como professor pode ser
importante mas ou milho importante
e o que é isso 1
você possui uma atitude positiva e
então passe o tempo para ambas as respostas hexadecimais
por bondade e você v6 100 é necessário
desfiles de sucesso
tome desconforto e um pouco de linguagem e del
comando dos vídeos stan mays vídeos que
era ser capaz de ler em inglês
eles importaram links e eastwood não são muito
ligado à desculpa pornô para poder fazer armas
york e português ok para ler deles